MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome
back to 8.701.
So now the theory about Higgs
boson is quite interesting.
And we have seen that it's
able to produce masses of boson
and of fermions.
But as Feynman said, a theory is
only as good as the experiment.
And so we have to
actually find Higgs boson
and measure their properties
and see whether or not
their properties are consistent
with the standard model.
And so the first
question we have to ask
is how Higgs boson
is actually produced
and how they might decay.
So this little video is
just talking about this
in very simple terms.
So we are able to
produce Higgs boson
at proton-proton machines,
at proton-proton colliders,
because they are able to
bring collisions or produce
collisions which allow to
have energies of a mass scale
consistent with the Higgs boson.
We already know now
that the Higgs boson
has a mass of 125 GeV.
So the collisions have
to have enough energy
to produce this particle.
We're using protons to
do this because protons
can be accelerated easier
than electrons, for example,
to those energies.
But protons themselves
are, as we have seen,
objects which consist
of quarks and gluons.
So how do gluons now
produce Higgs bosons?
And this is shown in
this Feynman diagram
here where you have two gluons
from two colliding protons.
And they are able via this
loop diagram, triangle diagram,
including the top quark-- the
top quark goes around here--
to cause an excitation
in the vacuum,
which is the Higgs boson.
They couple to the vacuum
producing the Higgs boson.
And then instantaneously,
the Higgs boson decays.
And it can do this
in various ways.
And we look at this
on the next slide.
And in this example, it decays
via a similar triangle loop
into a W. And then the W
is electrically charged
and can radiate a
pair of photons.
So while the gluons and
the photons are massless,
we are able to
produce Higgs bosons
via the collisions of
two gluons and observe it
via decay into photons.
This is quite spectacular.
In more general ways, it's
not just one mechanism
to produce Higgs bosons,
but there's various.
And the leading
ones are shown here.
We have just looked at
this first one, which
is called gluon fusion
channel, so two gluons
fuse together to a Higgs boson.
There's this one here,
the second one, which
is called Vector
Boson Fusion, BBF,
where we have the quarks
radiate to vector bosons.
This is either the Z
boson or the W boson.
And then those
couple to the Higgs
field and produce
the Higgs boson.
We can also have
associated production
where we have two quarks
via, again, a Z boson or a W
boson radiating then
a Z boson or a W boson
and generating a Higgs.
And then a very exciting
one is the last one here
where the Higgs boson is
produced in association
with two top quarks.
Remember, the top quark
here has a mass of 175 GeV.
The mass of the Higgs
boson is 125 GeV.
And so we have two of those.
So the scale of this event
is in the order of 500 GeV.
This plot here shows the
production cross-section
as functional center
of mass energy.
Now the Large Hadron
Collider, the LHC,
operates currently at 13 TeV.
So the cross-section we
want to look at those.
So you see that the leading
cross-section, which
is in the order of
tens of picobarn,
is the one where we
have gluon fusion.
On the order of
magnitude less is the one
with vector boson fusion.
And then we have
associated production.
And then the last
one is the one where
we have Higgs boson produced
in association with top quarks.
Because the mass
scale is much higher,
the cross-section for
TD Higgs is lower.
If you were to increase
the center of mass energy
of the LHC, you see this rapid
increase in cross-sections
just because there's
more phase base
available for this production.
The coupling here and the
coupling here is the same.
Then the Higgs boson,
as I said, decays.
And we have already discussed
Higgs branching ratios,
or branching ratios in general.
And since the coupling of
the Higgs boson to fermions
is proportional to the
mass of the fermions,
you see the dominant decay is
the one into Higgs to bb-bar.
And then you can
find lower decays
to the taus, the [INAUDIBLE],,
and to muons here.
You also have to into the
vector bosons, W-W, and Z-Z.
So similar triangle
diagrams, you
have decays into glu-glu,
and then to photons as well.
So we have already measured
the Higgs boson at 125 GeV.
And so those are the
branching ratios as
predicted in the standard model.